since the dawn of mankind we've not done
much together
as a planet maybe because getting
everyone everywhere to do anything at
the same time doesn't seem possible or
doesn't until 1967 when BBC executive
Aubrey singer creates our world a TV
show threatened for the whole world to
see and be seen in it all started with a
production in 1945 arthur c clarke has a
big idea if you have three satellites
and geostationary orbit then you can
send and receive a signal from almost
any part of the Earth's surface
Antti figures this out before satellites
even exist in 20 years his futuristic
idea is here by 1966 three new
satellites have gone up that are just as
our foresee Clarke predicted all going
around the equator and sank with the
Earth's rotation so they stay above the
same spot which is enough to get Aubrey
Singer thinking can he be the one to
take television into a new era by making
the first show the whole planet can take
part in he just has to persuade the rest
of the world to join in singer chuckles
the globe the old-fashioned way to drum
up support for his plan it's not the
easiest sale but his plan gets a boost
when the Beatles agreed to play live on
the show soon 19 countries are on board
and meet up to go through the script
each country will provide at least one
segment everything in the show will be
live our world will bring together
slices of life as they happen from all
around the globe on the 25th of June
1967 their plans become real as around
10,000 technicians and producers
worldwide get set to make history over
the
one and a half hours they'll have to
coordinate live feeds from all the
different countries
a stupendous feat of organization surely
it's gonna go horribly wrong in front of
everyone but amazingly it all works for
the first time in human history people
all over the globe are watching the same
thing 400 million of them thanks to
three satellites watching everything
from babies being born in Japan to
cities waking up in Australia and of
course the Beatles singing their
specially composed all you need is love
they're done it an astounding technical
achievement okay some say the show
itself was a little dull but if anyone
had any doubt about the power of
satellite broadcasting it was swept away
two years later when the whole world sat
down have watched television together
again this time of the moon-landing
scene by half a billion people thanks to
one giant leap for the information age
[Music]
you